I'm putting together video right now
that's going to have a really powerful
message and it just sort of showing
what's going on out on the fields right
now and like all the workers and have
asked like fans to send in clips of like
people who they know who are warriors
and so I'm shooting my clips from my
backyard but I just wanted to put the
song out to motivate to lift people up
and then and she also just to motive
they then to to keep up the fight
against scope at 19 absolutely you know
you mentioned your tour you're supposed
to be in Asia essentially right now was
that difficult I don't know not a
difficult decision knowing full well
what you have to do it to help flatten
the curve but was that difficult for you
to take personally knowing that you
couldn't get out there I think the
hardest thing about having to cancel the
head above water World Tour because we
had a Europe China Japan in Southeast
Asia I had to cancel the hardest part
about that was that I had like just
overcome Lyme disease in my own personal
health battle just got back out there
with my album head above water and was
doing this tour so it was such a bummer
sort of the fans but you know it's
obviously devastating to have to cancel
a tour when you put that much of
rehearsals and look we were like right
about to fly over there but every every
artist has had to obviously cancel their
tour so it's you know we have to all do
our part and keep everybody safe and it
would have been irresponsible to have
like large gatherings and plus we're
allowed to anyway at that point but so
it's unfortunate but you know we'll we
were rescheduling mm-hmm being at home a
lot of people are coping in different
ways and you just said now you know you
had all this energy and momentum are you
able to channel it into other artistic
endeavors are you writing more
you play more music at home like how
what's going on with that I've been
writing a lot of songs um I have a
studio in my house so that's nice so I
just recorded warrior two we are
warriors in my studio and um I've been
writing on other songs working on other
projects that are also coming out this
month and I've just been doing like a
lot of cooking cleaning
I used to Swiffer a lot and I consider
that to be my cardio because I sweat
when I do it's like all over the entire
house I'm like okay that was my cardio
for today so Jenna shoot cardio cooking
a lot um and like I said I'm here with
two people so like I'm just kind of
making this huge buffet like seven
course like meal and like soothing it
out on the counter and then we just like
eat that all day so we don't have to
like cook three four times a day
wiping down boxes with Clorox and doing
our part wearing face masks if we go out
and totally not going out I do not want
to get sick so I'm just doing my part
want to flatten the curb stay at home
you know stay safe keep everybody's
today I can just you know be responsible
about the whole thing and then the
meantime you know turn to music and I
hope that it's all just like um looks
people up and lifts their spirits up
yeah you're gonna start your avril
lavigne Swiffer workout series for
people so they can join along with you
I'm starting the officially now like
ever so like okay maybe this is a good
time that's perfect
is there anything that you wanted to say
specifically to the frontline workers I
mean you believe in them so much and you
want to inspire them and support them at
this time what do you want to say to
them and also to your fans that are
struggling right now I would like to say
that the frontline workers just a huge
thank you and then it's like I'm so in
awe of like how you guys are all coming
to
they're like all the doctors everyone in
the hospital even just people working at
the grocery store it's a really scary
time for everyone and we need all of you
guys like the mail delivery services and
you guys have really stepped it up and
been there for us and it's been really
beautiful to see and thank you so much
and you guys are the true heroes you are
all warriors we're all words together
even just by staying in and staying home
and everyone having to put everything on
hold to do the right thing